[Music]
thank you
I bet these boring minute and 45 second
blood sigil opening credits mean
something really cool if you're willing
to do a bunch of online research and
stuff
[Laughter]
research in the castle is surrounded by
a deep
dry mode thinking that your dry moat is
in any way an enticement It is Well
fortified against any future dornish
incursions I could have died and come
back to life five times and still not
know or care anything about Dorne beyond
their wine and that I haven't been using
the term dornish incursion as a metaphor
for spring break for the past 10 years
well in Blackwood doesn't have a bigger
part in this episode seriously I'd turn
a super cut of him stabbing fools over
the long drawn out conversations to
follow regarding who's making babies
with whom
saying this to the same person you
watched viciously stab a board of death
in the previous episode we should make
landfall inside the hour princess oh
good fast travel has been enabled I was
worried they might actually expand the
world and let us learn more about the
characters during their Journeys that
would have been terrible
Damon's a cheeky [ __ ] sure and I
might believe he's enough of a cheeky
[ __ ] that he wouldn't care about
damaging the boat or the people on it
but why is he putting his precious
character's at risk by breaking the
dragon hard deck rules I would say that
the show gives us one of those full
minute of pointless anticipatory walking
scenes here but it does include one
person sweeping the stairs so excitement
thinking you're not at risk because it's
just the tip once we smash the Truckee
they named me king of the narcy Roll
commercials this entire scene tries to
build tension out of Damon's arrival but
instead it just becomes two minutes of
boredom is someone nearby sexing up
their dead sister because I can't hear
anything over the deafening sounds of
the anti-climax he hasn't yet seen any
tapestries gifted to you by Novus and
Coho naming your children norvos or
kohor how romantic it must be to get
imprisoned in a castle of me to squeeze
out as I love princess Rainier's
steadfastness and not accepting her
gender roles I'm sure if she ever does
decide to have kids the show will do an
excellent job of helping us understand
her character's change of heart and
development instead of oh I don't know
skipping the entire 10 years when it
happens even matured yourself these last
four years princess you'll get used to
the attention this is just the tip of
the spear when it comes to how
uncomfortable this relationship is
ultimately going to make us I just
realized this boring conversation
between these two has been going on over
a minute now and I totally forgot I had
a skip button that's on me lovelies and
by on me I mean I'm sitting the show for
it oh and also
Royal skip I don't wish to cause you
further distress well then maybe don't
interrupt they hadn't completed that
last riveting section of the discussion
on the sea snake yet please let them fit
show things focusing on the candle being
held will distract me from realizing we
are yet again just watching people walk
around show is wrong
thinking you can tell anything from a
sniff test when you're in the in the
streets stage of civilization and we're
walking again I swear someone behind the
show was like you know the thing that
Sorkin does that people love the walk
and talk yeah let's do that except never
at the same time so anytime someone's
talking there'll be nothing to engage
the eyes visually and anytime people are
walking there's nothing to engage the
brain intellectually it will rule while
on its skull this looks like an over
candling situation but it's still
incredibly dark in here so my
professional recommendation is going to
be for bigger candles for going any
subtlety by using a rat as a visual
metaphor AKA departing
the show will use this dragonflame
transition so much in this scene that I
swear George Lucas called them and was
like fine I'll stop using wipe
transitions in Star Wars just cut this
[ __ ] out already bathed and confused you
have a far kind of touch than they do
we're now cutting between an uncle
seducing his niece in the Cirque de
Hornet District to a decomposing King
getting a sponge bath and passionless
sex from his Young Bride it's like the
show is purposely not giving us anything
we want to actually see and call me
crazy but eventually I'm gonna want to
see something that I want to see
good King
names his daughter a girl his air I
honestly didn't think we could get news
position in a world before television
but never underestimate the desperation
of scriptwriters I'm impressed Steven
full Copper Street rat Street rat but
would they buy that you'd think that
they'd look closer the King has
requested you a presence the hour is
quite late yes your Grace royal booty
calls I've given all the sins back of
this maidservant had just walked in and
said you up not that I can really show
you any of it but seen in a Game of
Thrones show uses nudity to pretend to
be interesting cliche Funko lunging
Damon I know the jig's probably already
up but did you really have to call out
his name so people knew without a doubt
who you actually are I guess what I'm
saying is shut your [ __ ] face uncle
[ __ ] wait is that the same rat from
earlier that's it if this isn't proven
later to be someone warging into this
rat to spy on people we Riot and now
these two are gonna copulate as well
because why not I swear as I'm watching
this show my dog is vigorously humping
her dog bed and truly there's no better
metaphor for this show in both cases I
just let them finish so we can both move
on with our lives at least I thought
they were gonna copulate it's almost two
minutes later and they're still taking
off their clothes I guess because this
relationship is super romantic and will
be so meaningful to them both for the
rest of the series
protection from a common law I'm not
casting judgment here just saying from a
public health standpoint this sounds
exactly like a situation in which
someone would need protection I learned
that the skin tray could only take me so
far in this life cool could you tell HBO
they were engaged in behaviors
Unbecoming of a maiden after that
viserys asks Otto to elaborate and we
get Damon and runira were seen together
in the bowels of a pleasure den and we
all know what this means but viserys is
playing obtuse and requests more
explanation and ultimately we land on
coupling that's it after all the
foreplay we get [ __ ] coupling which
may be the saddest wordgasm I've ever
experienced also using the word vowels
in the same sentence as pleasured in
what happened last night what happened
last night is a 2016 movie about college
students Danny and Sarah who wake up one
morning in bed next to each other after
a night a hard partying with no
recollection of what happened the night
before or how they met not a single
Rotten Tomatoes critic has reviewed it
and has a 3.6 rating on IMDb and I'm so
bored by this episode that I swear if
it's streaming anywhere I'm just adding
30 more sins and watching that terrible
movie instead of this
[Music]
and we'll see where every time oh it's
on Voodoo with ads and since I don't do
ads I guess just the ones in and we get
to slog for the rest of this episode
together yay
it's tupled which could be anything from
light spooning to mani pedis so I'm
still not sure how anyone knows what you
actually did first
mentality foolish of you to place
yourself in a position where your virtue
could even come into question blaming
someone for how others choose to see
them Damon's walkashame is just a
regular old vanilla Walk of Shame and
not the usual Ultra spicy Westeros Style
walk of shame read it to me I hate this
family which I guess it's fine because
at least I have
um well there was that one um
again from the beginning of the episode
was kind of fun is he coming back you
believe he lied how does confessing to
such things serve him are you serious
right now he literally just told you how
remember the whole wet hurt to me thing
from like five seconds ago from my blood
come the prince that was promised and
his will be the song of ice and fire all
of this seems really weighty and cool
until you remember they crown [ __ ]
bran you are my political headache
Twitter gods have a dark wind good they
pass along some of that wit to the
writers of the show asking for an
audience your interests no longer align
with those of the realm your judgment
has been compromised the issue here
isn't that King viserys is wrong he's
not the issues that this means we're
losing Otto Hightower who is one of the
only interesting characters in the show
this isn't gonna happen a lot isn't it
I'm sorry what is that a tea princess it
will rid you of any unwanted
consequences ruining the spirit of tea
time
foreign
azzy Craven nobody calls me chicken
needles nobody thank God
a crown for King
tell these people Something They Don't
Know About Me
[Applause]
Brothers don't shake hands Brothers
gotta hug
I'm the map I'm the map I'm the map I'm
the map
[Music]
collaborate and listen Tommy that's a
taping I took great care in its
preparation
sorry what is that